Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie. This will be my daredevil
born again video.
We just got a first look at Charlie Cox
while they're working on the series,
so we'll break it down.
And we've seen a first
look at Jessica Jones.
They're bringing back pretty much
all the Netflix defenders, like almost
all the Netflix characters, almost.
So we'll explain what the current plans
are, because this is just the beginning.
They're all coming back at the same time.
And we got another cool clip of Jon
Bernthal talking about the Punisher
and Kingpin.
For those of you that want to see Punisher
come back in the MCU
the same way
every brand new to the channel,
of course
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes.
They'll be filming the series
for pretty much all this year,
so we'll get a bunch more footage
from the series soon.
Recently, while production is ramping up,
Charlie Cox was spotted
while they were working on Daredevil Born
Again, the working title of the series.
At least right now, is out of the kitchen.
They might change that,
which is a reference to Hell's Kitchen,
which is Daredevil lives in primarily
its focus.
That's where most of the Daredevil
Netflix series took place.
We spent a lot of time there
during the Hawkeye series as well.
Daredevil operates all over New York City.
So does Kingpin.
But as we saw in the She-Hulk
series, it's not unusual for him to travel
outside of New York City on adventures.
He'll also be part of Avengers
five Qing Dynasty in Secret Wars.
So like, yeah,
he'll definitely travel off planet
because it'll be completely different.
Vibe Daredevil in space,
but you may have seen your feeds
blowing up the last couple of days
because Krysten Ritter is Jessica Jones
coming back to the MCU for Daredevil
Born Again Season one, you can see her
wearing a daredevil born again
t shirt here.
The logo is the exact same as the new MCU
version, the logo
that Kevin Foggy just debuted at D23,
the big Daredevil panel.
Aren't you supposed to talk about my show?
But your show
and I think you made my show
from your phone calls for never throwing
money Resistance.
Well, the funny thing about that is
they were both there for the Echo panel,
for the Echo episodes,
and they just stayed for the Daredevil
Born Again episodes all explained
what's happening during Echo soon, too,
because there's a big daredevil kingpin
storyline during that.
But they were just joking about whose show
Daredevil Born Again would be like,
Daredevil is in the title.
You think it's about him?
So Charlie Cox is like,
What are you talking about? My show?
But obviously Vincent D'Onofrio
just joking.
The kingpin is going to believe
that it's true.
It's all about him.
The reason why you're seeing Krysten
Ritter getting ready for Daredevil
Born Again is because, like I said,
they're doing 18 episodes in season one,
meaning they will be filming
for pretty much the entire year.
It was supposed to start releasing
episodes at the beginning of 2024,
but because they delayed Echo
till the beginning of 2024,
they might have pushed Daredevil Born
again, just like a little bit after that.
But you get the idea it's coming
right after the Echo episodes
because that's the way
the story is playing out.
According to reports,
Marvel also had a plan to bring Krysten
Ritter back as Jessica Jones
before this during the She-Hulk episodes,
which makes sense
because her day job is a paralegal,
so you'd expect her Jennifer Walters,
Matt Murdock, to cross paths
in the normal courses of their jobs
outside of being vigilantes.
It was a whole basis for Daredevil's
cameo on She-Hulk.
He was in L.A. as Matt Murdock
first as a lawyer.
They had a teaser while he was there
for his new daredevil suits as well too.
Like, it turns out that he's getting his
new suits from this person in L.A. now.
Loukachenko son made a couple of new suits
for me, so I ordered one.
Doesn't really look like it.
It's a little bit insulting.
A blind man's clothes,
the new suits that he references.
There are suits
that he'll wear in the future.
On the Echo series and Daredevil
Born again.
Like there are a couple other suits
that were made for him that we didn't see
because we won't see them
until Echo and Daredevil born again.
All the new ones are meant to be versions
of his comic book suits,
like the yellow one was based on his
very first red and yellow suit
from his first comics appearance.
That was why they had all the jokes
about it on the series, about it
looking like ketchup and mustard.
Like,
why would you wear such clashing colors?
Like, wouldn't
you want to not stand out in the battle?
He was wearing it
because it was his first comic book suit.
And obviously, like a lot of the logic
in those classic comics is really jokey,
is that I couldn't figure out who it was.
And I realized it was
it was the new daredevil suit.
And they've incorporated the
the gold or the yellow
from some of the earlier daredevil comics.
He'll also have a version of his classic
red suit, reimagined like a brand new
version of the red suit, not the same one
that he wore during Daredevil Netflix.
He'll also have a version
of his newer black suit,
not the classic one from the Daredevil
Netflix series.
Like the low fi black suit.
The new one would be like the back
in black costume,
which is just a little bit different,
like an upgraded black costume.
He might have more suits than that,
but those are just the ones that we know
about right now.
The story for Jessica Jones in the MCU
probably hasn't changed that much.
Even though they've moved around
some of the series
and they got rid of her
cameo scenes during She-Hulk.
I believe the reason she wasn't on
She-Hulk was because she was busy
filming another series at the time
and wasn't available to do those episodes.
But during the Echo episodes are supposed
to be a bunch of daredevil and kingpin
Because of Kingpin's relationship
with Echo, he's
meant to be one of the main
villains of that series too.
But in a much bigger way
than he was during the Hawkeye series.
Like during Hawkeye,
it was a pretty short cameo.
And even though there was a little bit
more of Daredevil
during the She-Hulk episodes,
that was still just a smaller cameo.
They're supposed to be more of them,
more scenes for them in the Echo series,
and it'll be the first time that Daredevil
and Kingpin are in the same series,
like in the same production
together in the MCU.
Even though canonically,
they're treating the characters
almost as the same versions
in the Netflix series.
They're picking and choosing
what parts of the canon
they bring forward
from the Netflix series.
But for the most part,
the series is supposed to be canon,
But according to Charlie Cox,
the reimagining some aspects from the show
shows like not every single little thing
is going to be something
that they carry forward.
A really good example.
That's why the yellow suit on She-Hulk
looked almost exactly the same
as the classic
red suit on the Netflix series.
Just to show you that most of that stuff
was Canon during the Echo episodes.
The story for Jessica Jones is supposed
to be that she's missing in Daredevil
looking for her.
Aside from the main story of Echo
versus kingpin and Daredevil versus
Kingpin going on.
So while they're all busy
in the background,
Daredevil is still looking for
Jessica Jones.
The whole idea with Kingpin is that Echo
didn't kill him at the end of Hawkeye.
They just made it seem that way.
This ending scene
is just right out of the comics.
Her back story on the series
is similar to the comics version.
She's from the Daredevil comics.
Like a lot of the She-Hulk villains,
most of the smaller,
funny villains were either like
Daredevil villains or Punisher villains,
because they're bringing
so many of the Netflix characters
into the MCU in a much more proper way.
Kingpin raised Echo to be his weapon,
lied to her, saying
that Daredevil killed her father
so that she'd be more effective
in trying to get rid of him for Kingpin.
Then, secretly, as we saw in Hawkeye,
it was Kingpin who killed her
father betraying her.
So they just did a version of that
on the Hawkeye series.
She shoots him in revenge the same way,
but only winds up blinding him.
And when he returns, it's
meant to be this ironic twist
because he's blind,
just like Daredevil for a little while.
But eventually he gets his sight back.
The whole thing with the Echo series
is supposed to explore some special powers
in mythology that they teased during her
bedtime story with their father.
Like they talk about this crazy magic,
the story that he tells her supposedly
that's going to turn into
like a real thing during the Echo series.
And it'll be that stuff
lead with regular crime thriller
because you have daredevil
kingpin characters.
Jessica Jones
might have a cameo scene in Echo.
I don't think she's supposed to,
but it's always possible if they change
some of that because they've shuffled
the series around a little bit.
There have been a couple of delays,
I think,
because they want to polish some stuff.
But he is supposed to find her
during Daredevil Born again,
and she's a bigger part of the plot
during that series,
like the way that you would expect her
when they say
that she's going to be
a big part of the series,
the way that Charlie Cox
talked about the episodes,
he said that Daredevil Born Again
would be just like the tone
and the vibe of the Netflix series.
But because they had so many extra
episodes,
they'd be doing way more courtroom scenes
like you saw during Daredevil Season two
when he was defending The Punisher,
who will also probably
come back in the MCU at some point.
I know I mentioned the Punisher, people
like when are they going to bring
Frank Castle Punisher back?
They're not going to recast
the role of Kevin.
Foggy
isn't planning on recasting Punisher,
but I don't know if they have plans
to use him during Daredevil Season one.
There are 18 episodes, so obviously
there's like a lot of cameo spots
they could use for people.
The other Netflix defenders character said
that they love to come back.
It's just a question of availability in
what room they have for them in the story.
Like what are they already doing?
Like Luke Cage, Colleen Wing, even Finn
Jones said that
he wanted to come back as Iron Fist.
You probably saw that recently.
Two news articles about Iron
Fist wanting to prove people wrong,
that he would come back in the MCU.
We'll see about that.
The bigger storyline
they're supposed to be doing
during Daredevil born again
in season one is Major Kingpin.
Like the whole idea in Marvel Phase five
just in general, all the movies,
all the series is
they're going with a very dark rain
inspired, overarching story
spinning out of secret invasion,
where the antagonists take control
and positions of power.
Thunderbolt Ross is supposed to become
president of the United States around
the same time, like in Captain America
for a New World Order,
which is being released
right around the same time
the date of a born again
is being released.
Val has already become director
of the CIA, now wielding enormous power,
which he's
going to use to create the Thunderbolts.
And it all spins out of what happens
with the evil Skrulls in secret
invasion in the whole idea
is that the villains, the antagonists,
start taking credit
for getting rid of them In writing
that wave of popularity
to even greater political power Kingpin's
story is just localized
to New York City, with him
basically taking control of New York City,
riding that wave
and turning it into something more
akin to a police state, like doing
really terrible stuff in the light of day
and people loving him for it
because of what happened with the Skrulls
Like,
look, see if we're not this hard core
and the skrulls
are going to take over the planet again
in Daredevil trying to be a hero amidst
all of that,
they kind of started to do that
during Daredevil Season three,
where Kingpin took this position of power.
Like the public started to love him.
He was kind of lying about what
he was doing, though eventually Daredevil
won out by making people
see him for what he really was.
So the kind of doing
a larger version of that, like a much
bigger version during Marvel Phase five.
This is Jon
Bernthal talking about The Punisher
and working with Vincent D'Onofrio
is kingpin in how much of a badass
he is in real life while they're doing
Punisher in kingpin scenes,
he doesn't
That guy is around like he's
so like he is.
So if you are if you are an antithesis
to what we are trying to do,
like director producer,
if you are not part of the artistic
journey dude, you are an enemy.
And he like, lets
you know it's like it's great.
Like I saw him like just completely,
just like crumble Marvel execs.
Yeah, yeah.
Daredevil. It was like, Oh, my hero.
For those of you asking, Kevin Feige
doesn't have plans to recast Punisher
or anything like that.
It's still meant to be Jon Bernthal
when he eventually comes back.
Big reminder to The Mandalorian Season
3 episodes just started.
You can click here for My Full
Mandalorian Season 3 Episode 1 video
and click here for my Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 2 Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.